the educational portal is a website that
provides some courses in these courses
contain projects that you can take to
the tp-link a platform and perform a
project based and course or a lesson
focused on a specific issue so here's
the platform what you can see is I can
log in I can log in with one of my
social media accounts now that I'm
logged in and get this welcome message I
can go to the two free courses that we
are offering right now this is a the
first phase so I can go over here go to
the next section introduction course
covers some of the basics as you can see
I've already started and provides you
here with a curriculum and lists out the
different lessons that are available one
of the lessons we want to take a look at
today is an overview of the T bio info a
user-friendly visual solution for
education and practical applications
this lesson provides this introductory
video and the video covers some of the
basics of the interface that you can use
so I'm going to go ahead and complete
this lesson now let's go over to the
t-virus the platform itself this is
something that you can view in the video
how it works and we will actually use
one of the transcriptomics courses to go
through an example project so if i go
over to the transcriptomics course you
will notice that it again will start
with an overview if we go through the
curriculum starts with a pre evaluation
form but the most important thing that a
lot of users in this is you actually
have to press on this button take this
course to start the lesson and be able
to click to these lessons I'm going to
go ahead and take this course on get an
email notification that says that I
enrolled into this course you can see
that my learning progress is set to zero
the pre evaluation form really helps to
evaluate levels of students that take
this course and I'm going to just
quickly fill this out so that you can
see my experience
so my response is no record and another
important thing is to notice that
there's a complete lesson button at the
end of each lesson going to click that
and what you will see is that now I will
have this green icon that says that I've
completed this course so the
introduction into next generation
sequencing RNA seek I'm going to start
with this video this video is a good
example of somebody has been doing this
for a long time and discussing some of
the applications of next-generation
sequencing as well as some of the
challenges in the machine learning space
and the course is really focused on the
different types of applications
methodology and an introduction into the
transcriptome as a part of the systems
biology that we will learn hopefully as
a part of these different courses
offered on our educational lab platform
so when we go into the biology of
transcription we're going to learn about
what are we dealing with what kind of
data where this data coming from what
are some of the elements of the RNA seek
process and why how do we generate this
data essentially a lot of times you will
see these external links for people to
be able to learn additional information
about the sections that we didn't think
were critical to a student trying to get
to an actual to an actual project so
this goes over a few sections related to
what type of data this is and how its
generated what are some of the other
methods to study the RNA expression will
also see what types of outputs we are
generating so you can see here from
bioinformatics perspective we're
starting to deal with the actual data
type with the files that look like this
with the reads and also some of the
challenges about analyzing those raw
reads
and so you can see that the next thing I
will go to is the quiz the quizzes are
fairly short and simple and you can
start the quiz and then you will be able
to answer these questions but let me
speak as skip over into an example and
that way we'll be able to go over to the
actual platform so the example that we
provide here is a project that will have
these different examples and we will use
this on the platform and to see an
example of a different differential
expression and pipeline so if I click on
this link right here and we'll get over
to a platform that looks like this and
this is my account as you can see over
here I'm going to select the
transcriptomics section so that is right
here I'm going to open this section
again I can refresh what the section
does here now that I am here let's just
follow the step by step so you can see
that the first step is I'm going to
upload some files and I'm going to
define the type of data that I have so
let's just make sure that this is set up
correctly it's fast queue files I'm
going to choose they're actually over
here we can read specifically our model
genome GTF and for organism will choose
human mouse because this project
contains both human and mouse genomes
and this is a concatenated genome now
when I go to upload my files you will
note over here a way to upload SQL files
which are just reference files for me to
use that reference to files that we
already have on the server you can see
over here that the file that was
downloaded is this SVL file what I will
do is just remove this PC extension
okay and now I will go over here and
right here I will do your L book upload
and just select my downloaded file okay
now click on this button so you can see
all of these files and continue the
explanation so I will have to drag them
from here to there now the problem that
you will see that I did is I selected a
single instead of pair and greed so let
me reset this real quick and instead of
SC I will select PG human mouse and
we'll do this again you're a book upload
and what you will see is that now they
are in pairs now if you hover over and
will be able to see the full file you
can see over here
and now we are doing two groups Group A
and Group B okay so what you can see is
ER plus triple negative ei plus triple
negative you know plus triple negative
so what I'm going to do is compare ER
plus will triple negative and the order
doesn't really matter here plus goes in
here
triple negative goes in here
okay
triple negative you're positive and then
once I am done I will click on continue
and now I see this section now let's go
back here and we'll see the list that I
have here these are the different groups
but also you can see now the pipeline to
generate an expression table we're going
to start and then King bowtie - and then
our same expression tables highlighted
and then end I'm going to name this
human mouse or [ __ ] negative test and
save and now I can on the pipeline
okay and you can click on this one
pipeline button right here and this is
my pipeline so you can see that it
started 1% and now what we will do is
we'll just show quickly here the my
pipeline section so you can see that
this is a processing so it's working
right now and now we're going to start
looking at the output file what are the
genes either forms and exil'd expression
tables